je
tu trouves il branche qui était tombé
sous divers et si je la laisse est bien
le chemin mais le cinquième
le sommet que je veux les voir mais
c'est un obstacle pour promettre un
voleur chaque printemps
jean paul couvy scheer dessine
inlassablement les sentiers de
randonneurs autour du massif de bavella
jean-paul et guides de haute montagne
c'est lui qui arrive et lili à 40 ans
déjà au monde entier que son île
la corse est avant tout une montagne
c'est cette nature c'est nature regarde
quelle quelle beauté ya un an dans ce
cadre tiens ce granit là c'est
formidable je sens je sens dans d'un moi
même cette force qui est en ce rocher et
moi cette je me frotte 7 euros chez à 7
cette violence de la nature ses couleurs
cet arrondi ses formes
si je tape un petit peu je sens aussi
l'odeur
je suis à la bifurcation du sentier cela
tue les prendre comme le petit poucet
jean-paul jalonnent tous ces sentiers de
pyramide de cailloux on appelle cela un
kern une borne naturel pour indiquer le
bon chemin aux randonneurs
lorsqu'il atteint le sommet face aux
aiguilles de bavella la montagne
rappelle à jean-paul toutes ses
conquêtes
vois tu regardes ton regard se porte un
petit peu sur ce cirque et bien j'ai des
tu vois des pointes de jallet baptisé
plus d'une cinquantaine
c'est vrai que ça me donne la fierté
c'est comme lorsque j'ai envie son
retour mais il ya personne qui a mis les
pieds c'est formidable je suis le
premier on est les premiers nous autres
des fois le piste à mettre le pied sur
us sur un sommet vierge à des sommets ou
chez eux mais qu'ils me qui me rappelle
des moments où j'ai laissé laisse assez
marquées à vie dans quelques semaines
des centaines de touristes vont venir
troubler la quiétude de cette montagne
ce sera le début de la saison pour
jean-paul mais aussi son cauchemar
certains touristes ne respectent pas la
nature
la corse recèle de nombreux trésors
comme la baie de santa giulia
ou encore les falaises de bonifacio et
sa réserve maritime
toute l'année des hommes protègent cette
nature exceptionnelle même les
professionnels du tourisme bichonnent
leur petit paradis connaît la peur sans
âge où l'on voit pas une toits de
maisons pour y chercher
pendant un an nous avons suivi la
famille abbatucci avec jean-charles le
vigneron l'alchimiste des vins corses
bio le secret de ces grands crus se
trouve sous nos yeux
ce qui donne tous les parfums au vin
rouge principalement c'est la fameuse
myrte de corse
ac c'est juste son frère jacques et
éleveurs peut- e c'est lui qui a
réintroduit sur ses terres une vache
préhistorique la vache tigre paysans
moderne et respectueux de la tradition
il est à l'affût de toutes les dernières
technologies
voilà donc ça c'est l'inspirent solide
comme un granit
jean paul est toujours le roi des
cagnottes de bavella égard aux touristes
qu'il ne respecte pas sa montagne
je suis corse je suis guide c'est ma
terre c'est mon pays et je la protège
[Applaudissements]
et puis il y à dorine l'ange gardien des
vacanciers le tempérament de cette jeune
toulousaine a conquis le coeur des
corses
vous venez d'arriver mais sinon vous
venez combien de temps sa vie en corse
est devenu un conte de fées alors elle a
décidé de tout faire pour s'installer
définitivement sur l'île de beauté
je fis
[Musique]
à une heure au sud d'ajaccio la vallée
du taravo et son maquis très dense
loin de toute pollution lecomte
abbatucci élèves en totale liberté 2 170
vaches et 350 petits veaux oui m ont
reconnu que te regarde tout ça son souci
ils n'arrivent pas à toutes les
surveiller car son domaine s'étend sur
plus de 500 hectares peut te alors
jacques a fait appel à la dernière
technologie
le drone de surveillance ont battu voilà
donc ça c'est l'inspirent
laurent dubois assure que grâce à son
engin l'éleveur va pouvoir garder un
oeil sur tout ses vaches et alors après
l'application est dit oui
elle te dit elle va dire la batterie est
à 97 %
d'abord il va te faire anormalement as
tu voi assistée gps il te dit que là
c'est bon ils te montre le drone
d'accord des scans des gens savent c'est
pouvoir grâce au droit d'avoir une vue
d'ensemble rapide on va pouvoir se
concentrer pour aller chercher la bête
qui manque les voir s'il ya des matches
qui font niveau à droite à gauche doit
son sur le maquis dans ce peut-être
qu'effectivement ça sera difficile
en tout cas c'est un projet passionnant
et j'espère que ça va j'espère que ça va
fonctionner on vous présentait nouvelle
mouche à quatre hélices
[Applaudissements]
or ils assistent à rien génial laisse
l'opposition génial voilà si je veux
monter un super alors la paix pourra
monter
d'accord voilà et après on enfile aux
salaires alors d'accord il va me dire ça
qui est important
quand tu vois sur la carte on est ici
d'accord ils ont ensuite besoin de peu
par les marchés regardent en train de se
sauver
fêtez dessus là ils ont peur rires ouais
mais c'est pas grave on a raison il faut
que c'est comme tout il faut qu'elle s'y
habitue à l'arrêt quand tu avances tu
vois tu découvres petit calibre ans avec
ceux de ce côté là ouais ce stick là
pour avancer
bon ça se fait qu'il ya un éleveur se
met à jouer avec un drone s'est pas trop
jouer c'est travailler mais c'est pas
travailler c'est travailler c'est que
l'idée c'est quand même de nous
faciliter la tâche pour aller rechercher
des bêtes
donc c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
maîtriser c'est pas évident ça me paraît
si je pensais que ce serait plus un peu
plus plus plus évident c'est tu vois
j'ai vu une vache et du réveil
tu vois ça c'est de la lâcheté tout seul
après ça c'est intéressant d'aller voir
savoir si c'est une vache qui a fait un
veau si elle est oui oui c'est lourd oui
il ya un petit d'un mois à 9 h avec le
petit vol ah ah ouais d'accord ok voilà
là on voit bien ce super assis dessus
d'accord c'est là encore super d'accord
avec ça c'est une tigresse
le but des gones ces deux flics et les
vaches pour pouvoir le surveiller l'idée
c'est qu'ils aient x et soit aussi
facile d'utiliser cette nouvelle
technologie qu'on utilise comme avant le
cow boy qui prenait son choix elle
pourra les chars le ton bon c'est vrai
d'avoir un cheval c'est sympa et tout
mais bon vu les surfaces et vu le temps
du de les parcelles et qu'on n'est pas
tout les unes à côté des autres c'est
quand même plus évident d'avoir un
groupe c'est une autre technique s'est
maintenu avec un élevage des 19e ça
voilà c'est le cheval du 21e siècle
[Musique]
maintenant on va voir qu'elle vive avec
une grosse mouche a fait un bruit de
mouches et vont se dire tiens y'a une
nouvelle race de mouches qui est arrivée
en corse ces vaches tigres sont un
véritable trésor pour la corse jacques
refuse de faire de l'élevage intensif
son rêve est ailleurs il va participer
au trophée national de l'excellence bio
mais la corse a bien d'autres trésors
l'un des plus fragiles se trouve dans
les bouches de bonifacio
sous cette eau pure et transparentes
c'est en une forêt sous marine la
posidonie une plante qui ré oxygène la
mer par photosynthèse l'été la posidonie
est en grand danger
alors chaque printemps les gardiens de
la réserve maritime de bonifacio
multiplie les sorties des centaines de
propriétaires de bateaux ont tendance à
prendre le littoral pour un parking
[Applaudissements]
ils s'arrime à ces bouées sous
lesquelles se trouvent des énormes blocs
de béton qui détruisent la posidonie le
poumon de la mer le problème que l'on
rencontre c'est ça c'est une plaie
prolifération de ces corps mort est
licite
quand on commence à avoir des centaines
de blocs de béton mais m² de mètres
carrés trop mètres carrés sur la
possible ni on arrive après avoir un
super fassi des ddd des centaines de
mètres carré de peau sidonie recouvertes
les plongeurs de la réserve maritime
utilise une technique empruntée au
renflouement des pav
malgré leur poids les corps morts sont
remontés facilement à la surface grâce à
un parachute rempli d'oxygène pour
éviter que les nouveaux plaisanciers de
la saison d'été viennent s'installer au
milieu de la réserve maritime
l'équipe de paul péché se pressent de
nettoyer toute la zone
à quelques kilomètres de là santa giulia
un lagon baignant au pied des montagnes
à la sortie de porto vecchio
cette plage est l'une des plus prisées
de la corse du sud
à chaque fin de printemps les
professionnels du tourisme lui redonne
un coup d'éclat
m
ce à quoi ça va super et grands alors là
c'est des amis de la saison on retrouve
tous les hors la co là c'est la famille
de la place avec nanou avec qui on se
retrouve à la un an après c'est la 17e
saison pour fred responsables du club de
ski nautique de santa giulia
il vient tester aujourd'hui la solidité
des fondations de son pantin malmené
pendant l'hiver
on va changer toutes ces pièces on va
arranger les poteaux quelques heures
ouais ouais c'est bien ça va repartir
mais oui voilà on attend d'eux plus que
de poser le beau tapis bleu pour
accueillir les clients avaient là vos
quêtes la petite cabane balinaise et
c'est reparti pour la dix septième
pour profiter pleinement de la vue il
faut aller à l'autre bout de ce petit
paradis
paul restaurateur a le sourire
c'est pas mal car le point de vue de sa
paillote est unique c'est pas mal et à
pierre comme endroit devant ses
terrasses l'eau et cristalline et le
paysage encore vierge
ici la nature regardez on voit pas une
construction connaît d'après le sondage
où l'on voit pas une toits de maisons
vous pouvez chercher magnifique mais la
saison débute mal paul a dû reculer
l'ouverture de son restaurant de 15
jours
il vient de faire une découverte
catastrophique des bons plans
un grand classique pour les paillotes en
bois durant l'hiver des locataires
discret se sont installés dans les
poutres de la terrasse les termites en
manger toutes les poutres à deux sous
donc il faut se refaire dégâts sont là
sans la en ce début de saison
suivant la loi des séries les ennuis
pour paul s'accumulent des travaux vont
débuter sur l'unique route qui accède à
la plage de santa giulia et à son
restaurant
on fait des travaux dernière minute
excusez moi on est en en saison là on a
commencé les travaux mais en plein hiver
ont commencé travaux maintenant voilà
ces autres que préjudiciable
paul est irrité ses clients ne pourront
plus se garer devant sa porte
ce catastrophique à la 50e place de
parking jean supprimé 15 le dernier
week-end de mai la corse du sud voit
débarquer une première vague de
touristes
[Applaudissements]
mais déjà les pompiers multiplient les
interventions dorine et pompier
volontaire depuis cinq ans à la caserne
de porto vecchio
[Musique]
il ya deux voitures en cause apparemment
et on compare avec tambour ainsi à le
secours routier qui vient
[Musique]
au volant d'un 4 4
un touriste belge a percuté un autre
véhicule avec à son bord deux personnes
âgées
bonjour la passagère arrière est choqué
elle pose et le vent sa soeur la
conductrice indemme est encore sous le
coup de l'émotion
oui non rien et le bas du dos l'air du
temps non non non je n'aime pas cogner
j'ai freiné l'air bag a déclenché gepam
iphone était ceinturé oui au niveau de
la faisait mal non le l'airbag à
déclencher ou pas non par contre si on
enterre fusion va la manger non c'était
vrai visage
samedi dorine c'est bon on va
[Applaudissements]
les accidentés s'en tire avec quelques
contusions
dorine et pompier volontaire depuis
l'âge de 16 ans c'est un drame personnel
qui a déclenché sa vocation 11 ans
maintenant
j'ai eu un grave accident de voiture
donc je pense que s'il n'y avait pas eu
tout ce qui est aide-soignant pompiers
infirmière à ce moment là je ne serais
pas là aujourd'hui et quand j'ai su que
ben c'est bon j'ai été tirés d'affaires
je suis sorti l'hôpital je rejoins de
toute ma famille et tout ça j'ai dit
c'est ça que je veux faire quoi donc je
sais pas s'arrêter un espèce de déclic
[Musique]
pas le temps de se poser cette fois
c'est un malaise cardiaque dans un
camping de porto vecchio
on a huit minutes je reprends dernier
rendrait sur les lieux après
de retour de la plage
un touriste italien a fait une syncope
[Applaudissements]
l'homme indique qu'il a déjà eu des
problèmes cardiaques
voilà un pacemaker l'attention du
patient est très basse il doit être
transporté d'urgence à l'hôpital
un journaliste français
[Applaudissements]
la journée de dorine pourrait s'arrêter
là mais entre deux permanences chez les
pompiers
elle exerce un deuxième métier
merci
une religion c'est par ici
dorine la pompier volontaire a été élue
miss corse
elle inaugure aujourd'hui une foire
artisanale votre notre belle miss way
complète famille la plus grande pour moi
que tu ai regardé un peu grande et
adorable est adoré le changement de nice
où domine aussi alors je déclare m la
voir de porto mais
une miss corse se doit d'avoir le
sourire en toutes situations
dorine pose volontiers avec ses
admirateurs et affectionne
particulièrement les spécialités corses
des beignets hoobrouck spécialité c'est
très bon pas trop diététique mais c'est
très bon voulez goûter
tu es bien tenu même michel à l'egypte
ou meilleur portrait d'un gros gégé de
caroube de mon mieux pour pour assumer
cette écharpe et jongler entre la
responsabilité de nice
le boulot à côté qui nous prend pas mal
de temps et j'espère que j'ai à combien
dernière pause avant de prendre la route
miss corse est attendu également à
l'autre bout de l'île à bastia
préfecture du département de la haute
corse
elle a rendez vous pour une séance photo
avec renée marie ancien couturier de la
maison dior
ils mettent une dernière touche à une
robe de mariée créée spécialement pour
elle le styliste a été conquis par la
personnalité de dohring moi je valide
orange védrine pascal est à la fois
nissa et pompiers si on peu incohérent
nous mais c'est hyper féminin c'est
vraiment la féminité pousse à l'extrême
et pompiers c'est attention s'instille
skinny ça c'est un métier d'homme à ce
que couturier sa métier de femme à
[Rires]
devenir miss était un rêve pour dorine
mais elle n'avait jamais osé se
présenter son conte de fées a débuté
d'une manière surprenante
un soir au bal des pompiers ses
collègues l'inscrivent à son insu à
l'élection de miss corse
sur le coup je pensais qu il rigolé
quand j'ai vu que non salut je me suis à
toi j'ai pas le profil qu'est ce que je
vais faire ce soir là à cette élection
et au final donc voilà je me suis projet
en fait je me suis pris au jeu et j'ai
même pas tu accuses et de me dire pour
que je gagne faut que je gagne je me
laisse embarquer la séance photo a lieu
à la citadelle la bastille à qui a donné
son nom à la ville de bastia
en cette saison elle n'est pas encore
prise d'assaut par les touristes
mais la météo est capricieuse et a fait
chuter le thermomètre à 10 degrés tu as
très très chaud c'est la méthode coué tu
t'y penses pluviales fait pas froid
aujourd'hui tu me fais très vite renée
marie entraîne sa troupe en direction du
port sa flore a pu
bon mari oui c'est moi et oui j'ai
pousse des trois c'est la mode
alors vous avez monsieur c ces nouvelles
tendances maintenant avant que les
commerçants du marché ne quitte la place
saint nicolas
la photographe paul santoni improvise un
nouveau décor et mesdames un plus aux
tories sur l'armée naturel les pompiers
n'ont pour dorine cette séance photo est
une sorte de test entre la femme pompier
la femme mannequin alors le métier de
mannequin est aléatoire
celui de miss éphémère et dorine ne
souhaite pas devenir pompier
professionnel
alors elle s'est lancé dans des études
d'aide-soignante si elle veut envisager
définitivement son avenir sur l'île elle
devra d'abord réussir son examen
l'été les vacanciers affectionne la
corse du sud ils envahissent la plage de
santa giulia pour le bonheur des
commerçants corse qui est en deux mois
pour faire leur chiffre d'affaires
[Applaudissements]
la montagne connaît elle aussi un succès
grandissant
[Applaudissements]
le massif de bavella et ses majestueuses
aiguilles situé sur la partie sud est de
l'île et le lieu de départ
incontournable de tous les randonneurs
l'arrivée de jean-paul au col marque le
début de la saison
lorsqu'il arrive le guide est accueilli
comme une star je peux premier guide
corps jean-paul
on va dire c'est le seulement 1,2 de la
montagne c'est le notre père à tous est
une référence
on a eu comme l'a eu comme mamie on a eu
comme le formateur même temps non
content de le voir de voir qu'il est
toujours malgré ses 73 printemps
jean-paul guide au pas de charge un
groupe de jeunes inscrits pour un
baptême de canyoning
bon allez les jeunes allaient les dames
viennent derrière moi ce canyon du loup
vers en 92
il ya le policier d'où le port karak et
la bac il ya trois canyon qui sont
intéressants le pouce qu'elle je le fais
pas parce que ce canyon facile je le
laisse à ma grand mère qui elle elle
fait que sa mémé et l'a 89 ans et c'est
comme ça alors faites attention là
faites attention à traverser
dans les années 80 c'est canyon était
désert c'est guillaume naud je pense que
la cheville est de jouer laissez-passer
ait en groupe
merci tout à l'heure jean paul kunigis a
fait naître bien des vocations chez les
jeunes insulaires
avec lui le canyoning est devenu une
mode qui provoque parfois des
embouteillages en pleine nature
aujourd'hui je parie qu'il va y avoir
facilement de deux à trois cents
personnes qui vont passer qu'ils vont
aller hockey aux cascades
oui une dalle vos pieds à plat
chaque année de plus en plus de
randonneurs amateurs partent à
l'aventuré par leurs propres moyens et
font du camping sauvage
une pratique interdite que jean paul
kunigis ne tolère pas bonjour c'est pas
bien ce que vous faites là vous n'êtes
pas respectueux du pays
c'est quoi ça tu sais quoi vous y'a pas
du camping
vous avez peur de payer si tout le monde
était comme vous qu'est ce qu'on fait
allez je peux ou voir la nettoyer je
suis corse
je suis guide c'est ma terre c'est mon
pays et je la protège
on est d'accord pour que les j'avais le
tourisme mais le tourisme il faut que ce
qu'ils soient respectueux
merci
ça me met en colère parce que parce que
c'est toujours pareil je veux protéger
au maximum
si on dit que la corse est belle la
corse la corse est laid elle est
authentique est là la belle nature mais
il a fallu il a fallu la protéger nature
bien sûr c'est beau venir camper mais
aussi tout le monde fait ça c'est le
bordel après une demi heure de marche
sous un soleil de plomb la récompense se
trouve 50 mètres plus bas
oh c'est là bas si je tombe dire je
lâche et c'est lui qui fait mon travail
je te laisse hélas pour le rappelle pas
d'accord allez on a 40 50 m de rappel je
sache pas libère coupures d'eau jouent
au vote vers moi bien me vois bien bien
mais non bien ici c'est parti obama
noisette
allez allez on réfléchit pas aller jouer
oui oui oui bien sûr allez c'est parti
allez lâcha t final est allé au bout de
ce oui vous vous approchez là c'est bien
le carton plein et garde que les filles
merci je vois les sourires des mois et
sourire oui oui oui il fasse des sens
qui fait une descente
lorsque j'arrive en bas et disait bon
c'est un fait défaut c'est facile je me
suis régalé je me suis amusé j'ai pris
du plaisir
ils sont prêts à recommencer c'est ça
l'important
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la suite du périple
prend des allures de parc d'attraction
avec ses toboggans naturels
après trois heures de crapahutage c'est
au tour du vétéran de montrer de quoi il
est encore capable
[Applaudissements]
dans la vallée du taravo à 50 km au sud
d'ajaccio
les vaches tigres du conte abbatucci
s'ébattre en toute liberté
depuis le printemps son cheptel et sous
bonne surveillance
le drone fait sa ronde
mais les vaches ne semble toujours pas
habitué à sa présence
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour rentabiliser son élevage bio
jacques s'est transformé cette fois en
cuisiniers alors on va vérifier qu'elle
est assez de bois et il a mis au point
un dispositif ingénieux une cuisine
ambulante pour faire cuire un veau anti
à la broche ça c'est la broche voilà
donc on a assez de bois la duchesne de
l'olivier sauvage ça c'est bon le but ce
n'est pas de le fumer ne vaut donc c'est
de le cuire qui est un petit parfum
grâce aux chaînes et olivier mais pas
plus
voilà vous dépêcher parce qu'il faut
cuire alors il faut faut 10 heures de
cuisson si les gens vont manger à 9h
faut pas traîner
voilà donc on y va
le veau à la broche à domicile
cette spécialité lui a ouvert bien des
portes aujourd'hui
jacquat rendez vous sur la plage de
santa giulia où est organisé un grand
banquet
mais en haute saison le conte abbatucci
a du mal à quitter son maquis ça y est
la série route des plages
ça y est ça commence à devenir l'enfer
des files de voitures moi ça m'agace
profondément j'ai choisi d'être d'avoir
une vie à la campagne
c'est vrai qu'on est obligé de faire
avec va sortir le bébé
le bébé en question pèse plus de 80 kg
c'est bon là je l'attends vas-y à temps
mais c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon tir
voilà nickel oui les brancards
l'ambulance à quoi ça sert ouais et
adaptez vos bronches
c'est bon doucement les gars doucement
doucement à l'est
c'est festif et en plus ça c'est sa
nuque astérix noms sont liés ça fait
petit là ça fait pas petit jour c'est
parti pour dix heures de cuisson la
plage de santa giulia n'est qu'à une
heure et demie de la ferme de jacques
mais pour véronique son épouse qui vit
en corse depuis plus de dix ans c'est
une visite quelque peu exotique
ouais mais bon c'est la première fois
vrai quoi ce choix parce que le gamin
quand vous sortez à porto rico en
sortait en boîte à porto vecchio en
espagne et la mairie moins bon bon
maintenant je ne viendrai pas pendant la
journée la lettre de mon âme ou non un
peu sauvage aussi à la campagne à
l'autre bout de la plage comme une
personne quatre personnes paul le
restaurateur a enfin réglé son problème
avec les termites et les travaux devant
sa porte
[Musique]
sa terrasse comme chaque année affiche
complet tenez je vis à dépiauter la tête
il ya des jaunes ça y'a trop de travail
pour moi
de prendre la relève allez
[Applaudissements]
à 21h30 le veau tigre bio de jacques est
enfin prêt à être dégusté par 150
convives qui reste juste sur la colonne
extra et pour être sûr de son succès
jacques a préparé une potion magique une
sauce inimitable dont la recette est
transmise depuis plusieurs générations
l'énergie est source 'nos al-amud corse
mais c'est celle que faisait ma mère est
donc j'ai repris exactement ce qu'elle
faisait parce que c'était tellement bon
en fait rien n'a changé de vin différent
de l'huile du thym laurier c'est le
poireau oignon ail quatre épices il faut
voir surtout avec c'est pour ça que j'ai
toujours la pression parce que
finalement mais c'est risqué
chaque fois on se remet en cause c'est
tellement important je vais pas envie de
le louper quoi pendant des années j'ai
galéré donc un moment il faut assurer
quoi
les invités de ce soir sont de fins
gourmets le veau de jacques doit
absolument être à la hauteur de sa
réputation
c'est une danse et textures douces
trentenaire délicieux la sauce excellent
jacques fait partie d'une des plus
vieilles familles de l'île l'éleveur est
l'héritier d'une longue dynastie de
compte
le vigneron et mon fils antoine le fils
de jacques a fait le voyage de barcelone
où il travaille dans la finance
c'est lui qui un jour héritera du titre
de comte abbatucci rendez compte 450
donc c'est quand même
il est un poids sur les épaules le
pauvre c'est que il faut l'entretenir il
faut il faut il faut la faire vivre
parce qu'à un moment c'est cette vie qui
est importante avec avec ses traditions
de ruralité de valeurs d'honnêteté le
droiture le des gentillesses moi je fais
mon petit bout fera
entre un moment où je reviendrai encore
le veau braisée est un franc succès
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au mois d'août
porto vecchio multiplie sa population
par dix les touristes profitent de la
fraîcheur du soir pour visiter la
vieille ville
les à la caserne des pompiers les
interventions s'enchaînent sans relâche
sa des 46e quoi personne malade lui
permit les plages de dorine est encore
de garde
il est minuit la caserne vient d'être
appelé par un centre de vacances
[Musique]
une touriste allemande a fait une
mauvaise chute
on a déçu à la clinique
on va passer une radio ma chaise
j'espère que c'est pas casser parce que
j'ai évidemment pas de chance c'est son
premier jour de vacances venez d'arriver
mais sinon vous venez combien de temps à
deux semaines à attendre je peux faire
quelque chose aussi avec toutes ses
activités
dorine a du mal à trouver le sommeil est
comme ça ça suffit on sait que ça
commence à 8h le matin que ça fini à 8
heures le lendemain matin
ce qu'on va dormir ce qu'on va pas
dormir on sait pas trop donc on n'a pas
le temps beaucoup de se poser enfin
surtout moi cet été avec les miss en
plus du travail des pompiers s'arrête
pas
le lendemain matin dorine s'accordent
enfin une journée de répit à la plage de
santa giulia
elle est en compagnie d'anaïs une autre
pompier volontaire venue elle aussi du
continent un an déjà que dorine s'est
installé à porto vecchio
plus question pour elle de retourner
vivre dans la région toulousaine
ça a été un déclic en fait j'ai faim je
voyais je me voyais pas aller ailleurs
que qu'ici une fois que je suis venu
m'installer ici pour faire la saison la
première fois au moment de repartir
j'ai eu beaucoup de mal à la ville
l'odeur l'a vu la mentalité qui avait
interdit qu'une chose c'est de revenir
pour de bon m'installer ici
les clichés ont la dent dure notamment
que la corse et ses habitants ne
l'accepterait pas facilement les
continentaux savoir rester discret quand
on arrive et on sait rester à notre
place par nivet en terrain conquis sur
moi je viens de tours juin de paris
je connais mieux
les personnes dans le même cas que nous
sont pas corse de sang mais son camp ce
de coeur avant de reprendre leur garde
difficile pour dorine et anaïs de
résister à cette eau cristalline de 23
degrés je m'entends plus la porte ça
un peu plus haut il y en a d'autres qui
aiment profondément la corse a dit
caveau le village de la famille
abbatucci aujourd'hui une grosse fête se
prépare
elle n'a lieu qu'une fois par an ces
batailles par traitement donc c'est
vraiment même gabarit de grâce chaque
année la statue de saint roch traverse
le village de chica vaut la procession
se termine dans l'enceinte de la maison
des abbatucci dont il est le saint
protecteur lesaint reprend sa place à
l'entrée de la maison jusqu'à l'année
prochaine
une tradition immuable depuis quatorze
160 aujourd'hui le comte abbatucci
accueille les parents proches
les cousins éloignés et les amis le plat
de résistance et bien sûr le veau à la
broche attend qu'un bon petit bout de
grille et non
raymond tient un tire bouchon
jean-charles le cadet des abbatucci et
vignerons voilà il est impatient de
faire découvrir sa nouvelle cuvée
cette année elle porte le prénom de sa
fille bien voilà l'accusé faustine et
faustine toujours des histoires de
famille bah oui c'est comme après vous
avez vu aussi les cuvées qui met on va
dire à l'honneur mes ancêtres avec la
cuvée du général la cuvée du diplomate
la cuvée du ministre et ici on est
vraiment dans le berceau avec toute
l'histoire de la famille qui fait
vraiment partie intégrante de notre vie
ainsi si saint roch veille sur la
famille le conte abbatucci et le gardien
de la mémoire familiale
il nous entraîne au premier étage de la
casa pour faire un voyage à travers le
temps alors là c'est pas musée puisque
c'est notre maison
on est tous nés ici cette chambre là ici
donc je peux aller un peu en désordre
donc je vais pas vous lancer
mais c'est là c'est la chambre où tout
le monde est né moi aussi
le salon aux allures de cabinet
particulier expose toute la dynastie
d'hommes politiques et de généraux de la
famille qui ont marqué l'histoire de
france et celle de la corse
ça c'est cesser le ministre et le garde
des sceaux
il est mort en fonction place vendôme et
donc on va renvoyer toutes ces affaires
bien évidemment dans sa pochette de
ministre napoléon tran et on a toujours
les documents d'époque avec mais les
en-têtes regard des mystères de la
justice 1850 elle fait un peu des
bêtises des fois des coloriages sur ces
séquences est petit mais vous prenez des
papiers que vous trouvez pour faire des
coloriages alors sur un papier dans tête
ministère de la justice de 1854
c'est quand même un peu dommage dans
cette armoire l'uniforme restée intacte
de jean-charles abbatucci général de la
révolution mort à 26 ans contre les
autrichiens pour ce fait d'armes
son nom est gravé sur l'arc de triomphe
non c'est quand même un peu fragile 1
mais oui c'est ma taille parfaitement
donc c'est vraiment même gabarit
je me sens comme un agriculteur avec des
gaz ancêtres il illustre voilà c'est
tout pas plus si beaucoup de poids mais
voilà c'est pas moi qui méritait c'est
[Musique]
l'hymne de la famille abbatucci rappelle
que la dix huitième génération est bien
là jacques l'éleveur et jean-charles le
viticulteur marqueront ils à leur tour
de leur empreinte l'histoire de la corse
[Musique]
pour les titres de gloire dans quelques
semaines une belle surprise les attend
[Applaudissements]
depuis la terrasse de sa maison
chaque matin jean-paul observe la météo
s'il aperçoit clairement les aiguilles
de bavella c'est bon signe
la lumière sera belle aujourd'hui il a
rendez vous avec philippe pierre angeli
le photographe spécialiste de la
montagne corse
il vient réaliser son portrait quand
est-ce vrai avait aussi jean paul
prépare son prochain livre il rebaptise
dans sa langue corse
tous les sommets des aiguilles de
bavella c'est ce taux n'avait pas de nom
et c'est moi qui les ai nommé pour ta
longue c'est moi punta c'est moi pour
taio là c'est moi où tu azur gmt at war
vi qui est en face ça n'existait pas
ben ali quand tu continues grimpera dans
quelques années tu vois tard à la carte
j dira tiens là je suis drôlement de la
montrer à nos villes
alors si tu vois c'est vraiment le
maquis pour la séance photo jean-paul a
choisi un lieu symbolique le mon sens
tout bien bien là si tu continues le
chemin tu arrives sur le gr 20 qui fait
baver la conca ici tu es sur un sommet
qui a été mon premier ascension lorsque
j'avais 6 ans et demi sept ans je suis
arrivé ici avec avec ma mère ça me fait
plaisir de donner un petit peu cette
fibre kit qui est en moi et j'essaie de
la faire passer à travers des paroles tu
peux me regarder
ça c'est des bons moments de portraits
tué paisible là tu tues confiant
plus bas dans la vallée du taravo c'est
le temps des vendanges dans le domaine
de jean-charles abbatucci le frère de
jacques leroux je vous le ramasser aussi
richard tu vas rentrer ici ici là et on
prend tous seront là surnommé bioman par
ses collègues viticulteurs jean-charles
lance le début de la cueillette en
fonction de la position des planètes
c'est pas pour rien qu'on vendange est
ici ce matin parce qu'en fait on est en
jour fruit par rapport au calendrier
lunaire et que pour nous c'est très
important
jean-charles fait de la viticulture
historique
il respecte le savoir faire des anciens
on est en train de vendanger donc le
cépage des novices qui est un vieux
cépages de corps soyez qui fait quand
même des jolies grappin des grappes en
apparence prometteuse mais pour faire un
grand millésime
le premier test c'est le goût on va
goûter un raisin en fait on va avoir
avec ça un juge excellents et du coup un
vin excellent connu bonheur
cette année la cuvée s'annonce
exceptionnel
[Musique]
non loin de là quelques vaches tigres du
conte abbatucci sont descendus dans la
plaine du taravo pour jacques les eaux
de son domaine c'est un peu comme un
immense jardin un maquis laissé à
l'abandon
on pense que dans les anciens de temps
mais on était plus on pense à la
préhistoire le maquis les forêts tout ça
non celle inverse
aujourd'hui on a la préhistoire regardez
ça on est reparti dans les maquis alors
qu'avant c'était tout cultiver
là on a en a ce qu'est ce qui existait
avant ici avec des olivier rey côté y
avait pas un pied d'olivier qui était
pas exploiter toutes été exploités ont
récolté par tous alors jacques utilisent
les grands moyens et façonnent le
paysage à coup de bulldozer
cette initiative n'est pas pour déplaire
c'est vache tigres vous allez voir
comment on fait pour démaquiller et
comment on nourrit les vaches aussi en
même temps
le bruit du bulldozer attire toutes les
gourmandes des alentours
[Applaudissements]
s'ils ont des bêtes ils sont tellement
rustique que dès qu'on commence à faire
ce type de travail tout de suite elles
arrivent et ils vont se nourrir pendant
toute la nuit on reste et a mangé ses
feuilles d'olivier
[Applaudissements]
j'ai créé un grand parc beau parc elles
ont leur espace c'est leur maison leur
maison avec leur garde manger tout ça et
s'organisent
parce qu'en plus les vaches pour qu'elle
soit que la viande soit bonne il faut
qu'elle soit bien et ça c'est la
zénitude des vaches et voilà à quoi
ressemblera le maquis de jacques dans
quelques années
parfois lorsqu'il y est obligé jacques
quitte son maquis quelques semaines plus
tard c'est à paris que nous le
retrouvons avec son épouse
la recherche permanente de l'excellence
avec ses vaches tigre lui vaut d'être
nominé parmi les meilleurs producteurs
de france la directrice de l'agencé
nationale du bio récompense aujourd'hui
la méthode d'élevage de jacques qui
associe tradition et modernité
mais pour la famille abbatucci c'est
avant tout une reconnaissance pour la
production corse et ce n'est pas terminé
pendant la remise des prix son téléphone
à vibrer
ce matin jls
c'est fait à l'élu mérite agricole une
distinction agricole donné par le
ministère en l'état s'était déjà génial
d'être nominé ici et en plus j'ai quand
même se dit policiers cannois secrétaire
qui a reçu la voiture porte paul ce
matin et qui veulent envoyer en photo
c'est génial une distinction qui viendra
s'ajouter au titre de gloire des
ancêtres de la famille abbatucci
ajaccio c'est aussi un grand jour pour
dorine elle passe son examen des deux
soignantes
[Applaudissements]
aussi des destinées à réduire les
contaminations des surfaces en trois
temps si tu sais ça ça tout va ni la
fatigue cumulée de ces dernières garder
son rôle de miss corse ont épuisé dorine
une petite révision de dernière minute
s'impose
c'est l'un des dossiers qui déverse en
dehors de dorine ne peut échouer à cet
examen de son succès dépendra de son
avenir sur l'île de beauté
je pense que c'est une priorité les
études heures
c'est vraiment pour préparer en métier
pour pour ma future voire professionnel
et du coup c'est important que que je
valide ça aujourd'hui je vous donne les
sujets savez bien révisé 8 heures donc
mais vous commencez bon courage jusqu'à
9h30
les résultats seront connus dans
quelques jours mais la journée de dori
n'est pas terminée direction porticcio
à une demi-heure d'ajaccio dorine
rejoint les répétitions de la prochaine
élection de miss corse
[Musique]
les futures miss préparent leurs
chorégraphies
[Musique]
le conte de fées s'achève ce soir
elle rend sa couronne
[Musique]
la voilà moi aller vers les gens
elle est mal aux yeux
[Musique]
la fatigue
nick easter qui ont dit qu à l'attelage
noir le moindre et fric voilà on passe
le flambeau
c'est comme ça
je
journée
[Musique]
et
une miss corse 2015 jessica
dorine a rendu sa couronne mais quelques
jours plus tard une bonne nouvelle lui a
fait retrouver le sourire
[Musique]
elle a réussi son examen et obtenu son
diplôme d'aide-soignante sa vie en corse
peut continuer
[Musique]
comme jacques abbatucci jean-paul
descend rarement de sa montagne
mais aujourd'hui il a un rendez vous
important chez son éditeur
je suis un peu anxieux c'est un jour
exceptionnel pour moi parce que je
descends exactement et ce prêt à la
plage pour la sortie du livre que où
j'ai travaillé pendant deux ans
je voulais bonjour ça va vous montrer la
barre et du ha
je suis descendu et frère de ben oui bon
boulot mais parce que ça a été fait
c'est dû à ce prêt alors alors les
premières à première vision des spu raf
le voilà je sais que vous attendez
beaucoup à la donc ça y est je sais que
ça fait ça flashe 1 c'est vraiment
vraiment la couleur la couleur des au
premier abord ce qui me plaît jean paul
a conçu son livre pour tenir dans la
poche des randonneurs et il a consigné à
l'intérieur toute la liste de ces
sentiers secret j'ai longtemps hésité à
garder tout ça pour moi mais la corse la
corse
elle est à tout le monde moi lorsque je
parle d'une fleur je parle de sentiers
où je parle d'une de quelque chose que
je découvre et c'est avec mes tripes que
je parle
avec ce livre l'année s'achève
pour ces 73 ans jean paul quiles ichi se
prépare pour sa prochaine expédition
loin de son île en patagonie
quand son regard se pose sur la cime des
montagnes corses une nostalgie l'envahir
il reste lucide dans ce combat entre sa
passion et le temps qui passe un jour la
montagne sur la plus forte que moi et va
me prendre mais je resterai pas la
randonnée surtout parce que c'est ma vie
c'est même sans ça ça ça je n'existerais
plus tu es prêt pour la nouvelle saison
je me prépare